Ang mga programming model ay mga pundamental na espesipikasyon na nagtatakda
kung paano istruktura ang software
at paano ito pinapatakbo — nagbibigay ito ng balangkas
para sa mga developer para ipahayag ang mga algorithm
at ayusin ang code, madalas na itinatago ang mga mababang antas na detalye
ng pinagbabatayan na hardware o execution environment
iba't ibang modelo ang angkop sa iba't ibang uri ng problema
at hardware architectures, na nag-aalok ng
iba't ibang antas ng abstraksiyon
at kontrol. Sa kabanata na ito,
susuriin natin ang quantum at klasikal na programming model
at titingnan kung paano natin pagsasamahin ang mga ito para sa mas malalaking algorithm
sa mataas na antas
magsisimula tayo sa programming model
para sa quantum computer. Isang pundamental na programming model
na pamilyar sa halos lahat ng quantum developer
ay ang quantum circuit. Hindi tayo magde-detalye
tungkol sa quantum circuits
dito dahil marami na tayong magagandang resources —
kasama na ang isang lecture ni Joan Waters.
Banggitin lang natin na ang circuit ay binubuo ng
isang hanay ng mga linya na tinatawag na wires na kumakatawan sa mga qubit,
pati na rin ng mga gate na kumakatawan sa operasyon sa quantum states,
at isang hanay ng mga sukat.
Isa pang mahalagang konsepto ng programming model
para sa
— ang mga primitives na ito ay kumakatawan sa pinakasikat na gawain
na gustong gawin ng mga user gamit ang quantum computer.
May dalawang primitives na available sa ngayon:
Sampler at Estimator. Ang Sampler ay nagbibigay sa iyo ng kakayahan
na i-sample ang isang state na inihanda ng quantum circuit,
at ang Estimator naman ay nagpapahintulot sa iyo na tantiyahin ang expectation value ng
isang observable para sa sistema sa state na inihanda ng iyong quantum
circuit. Ang huling konsepto
na pag-uusapan natin sa seksyong ito
ay ang transpilation. Ang transpilation
ay ang proseso ng pagsulat ng isang input circuit
para tumugma sa topology ng isang partikular na quantum
device
para sa execution sa mga maingay na quantum computer.
Katulad ng mga klasikal na compiler,
ang transpilation routine ay unti-unting binabago
ang istruktura ng circuit sa pamamagitan ng pagpapatakbo ng isang hanay ng mga pass.
Ngayon pag-usapan natin ang mga klasikal na programming model.
Maraming programming model
para sa mga klasikal na computer,
pero sa kabanata na ito magtutuon tayo sa dalawa —
ang pinakasikat: parallel programming
at task workflow. Sa pamamagitan ng dalawang modelong ito
kasama ang quantum programming model,
kayang ipahayag ang halos anumang hybrid
quantum-classical workflow ng anumang complexity.
Ang parallel programming model
ay hinahati ang isang programa sa mga sub-problema na maaaring i-execute
nang sabay-sabay. May dalawang pangunahing paradigm ng parallel programming:
shared memory parallelism at distributed memory parallelism.
Para sa ating layunin dito, tutukuyin natin ang distributed memory model.
Ang distributed memory model
ay gumagamit ng mga independyenteng proseso sa magkakahiwalay na core
o node kung saan ang bawat proseso ay may sariling memorya,
at ang komunikasyon ay nangyayari sa pamamagitan ng message passing. May
ilang konsepto na magiging kapaki-pakinabang na malaman.
Una ay ang proseso,
na isang independyenteng instance ng programa
na tumatakbo sa isang hiwalay na core.
Mayroon ding rank, na isang natatanging identifier ng proseso,
at pagkatapos ay mayroon pa ring Single Program
Multiple Data abstraction model,
na isang abstraction model
para sa computation kung saan ang isang instance ng programa
ay ipinamamahagi sa maraming node —
kaya ang source code ay pareho,
pero ang data sa mga node na iyon ay iba-iba.
Ang execution sa parallel programming model
ay nangyayari sa ganitong paraan:
ang isang programa ay ipinamamahagi sa maraming node
at naglulunsad ng maraming parallel na proseso.
Ang control flow ng programa ay tinutukoy ng rank,
o ng identifier ng proseso,
at ang komunikasyon ay nangyayari
sa pamamagitan ng message passing.
Ang task workflow programming model
ay nag-aabstract ng computation sa isang graph o DAG
kung saan ang bawat node ng graph ay isang partikular na task
o trabaho, at ang mga edge ay mga dependency at data
at ordering. Ang mga halimbawa ay makikita sa ating dokumentasyon.
Ang sequence na lagi nating pinag-uusapan sa quantum
computing — mapping, optimisation,
execution, at post-processing —
ay isang task workflow programming model
kung saan ang lahat ng task ay isinasagawa isa-isa
sa pipeline.
Pero sa task workflows,
hindi tayo nakatali sa sequential na pagkakasunod-sunod ng execution
at kaya nating i-execute ang mga task nang sabay-sabay.
Ang bawat task o workflow ay maaaring maging isang buong parallel na trabaho
sa sarili nito, kaya maaari kang mag-mix
at mag-match ng mga modelong ito para ilarawan ang mga algorithm
ng anumang complexity.
Subukan nating ilapat ang ilan sa mga konseptong natutunan natin
sa code. Una, susubukan nating patakbuhin ang simpleng hello world
gamit ang parallel programming paradigm.
Gagamitin natin ang Open MPI,
na isang implementasyon ng MPI protocol,
na siyang pamantayan para sa message passing
sa parallel programming.
Una, kailangan nating tingnan ang ating programa —
dito ginagamit natin ang mpi4py,
na Python binding
para sa MPI, at tulad ng makikita mo, ginagamit natin ang rank dito para tukuyin
ang control flow ng programa.
Kaya titingnan natin ang ating submission script.
Tulad ng makikita mo, gagamit tayo ng dalawang node,
isang task bawat node sa normal na partition.
At patatabuhin natin ang ating programa — maghihintay tayo ng kaunti
at maaari na nating tingnan ang mga resulta ng ating trabaho.
Tulad ng makikita mo, mayroon na tayong log output ng ating programa —
dito gumamit tayo ng dalawang node at dalawang proseso
na kinakakilanlan ng rank.
Tulad ng makikita dito bilang output,
rank zero at rank one, na ginamit para tukuyin
ang control flow ng ating programa.
Makikita mo na ang rank zero process ay nagpadala ng
ilang payload sa rank one process,
at tinanggap ito ng rank one process.
Pag-usapan din natin ang task workflows.
May mga tool na tinatawag na workload
management systems na espesyal na dinisenyo
para magpatakbo ng mga kumplikadong workflow,
pero para hindi tayo ma-overwhelm, gagamitin natin ang built-in
dependency feature ng Slurm
para buuin ang mga computational graph na iyon.
Una, kailangan nating ihanda ang mga task ng ating workflow —
ito ay ang parehong code.
Ang benepisyo ng pagkakaroon ng bawat isa sa mga task na ito —
mapping, optimisation, execution,
post-processing — bilang mga hiwalay na hakbang
ay maaari tayong magtukoy ng natatanging resource requirements
para sa bawat isa sa mga task. Halimbawa, ang mapping, optimisation,
at post-processing ay hindi nangangailangan ng
access sa quantum resources,
kaya maaari nating patakbuhin ang mga ito sa klasikal na partition.
Pero ang execution task ay mangangailangan ng
quantum resources, kaya patatakbuhin natin ito sa quantum
partition.
Ngayon gamitin natin ang dependency feature para i-chain ang mga task
sa isang workflow.
Tulad ng makikita mo, pinapatakbo pa rin natin ang
ating sbatch command na may flag na --parsable,
na magbabalik ng job ID,
at pagkatapos ay maipapasa natin ang job ID na iyon
bilang dependency sa ibang mga task
o trabaho. Tulad ng makikita mo, pinapatakbo natin ang
mga trabaho sa workflow na may dependency.
Kapag kumpleto na ang buong workflow, maaari na nating tingnan ang mga resulta.
At tulad ng makikita mo, nakabalik na ang ating expectation value.
At maaari rin nating tingnan ang lahat ng
resulta mula sa bawat isa sa mga hakbang.
Na narito rin lahat.
At iyon na ang seksyon ng programming model.
Sa susunod na kabanata, pag-uusapan natin ang mga advanced
algorithm.